une année de renaissance c'est ce que
constate le secteur associatif après
deux années de pandémie de kobe de 10,9
ce dimanche au forum des
clayes-sous-bois les 150 associations de
la ville ont pu observer une hausse des
adhésions en cette rentrée le forum de
l'année de l'année dernière a été
vraiment un forum de reprise où les
adhérents étaient relativement frileux
alors que cette année le premier tour
que j'ai fait au niveau des stands
d'associations démontre qu'il y a une
réelle reprise au niveau des adhésions
l'association les claies gr propose des
activités de gymnastique rythmique pas
de baisse significatif pour ses 200
adhérents cela a permis à l'association
de maintenir son budget annuel de 60000
euros
comme on ne pouvait plus faire de
compétition en fait on a eu
on a eu des finances qui ont été plutôt
positives mais l'année dernière on a
beaucoup dépensé parce qu'on a dû
proposer beaucoup de réduction à nos
adhérents suite à tout ce qui avait tout
ce qu'ils avaient perdu là on a on est
revenu à un financement normal
la situation s'améliore aujourd'hui au
niveau des bénévoles la structure on
avait perdu plus de 60% durant la
pandémie là on est aussi content de se
rendre de ce début d'année parce qu'avec
le coc vide on avait perdu beaucoup de
bénévoles qui pouvait nous aider au au
cours de l'année à faire des actions au
sein du bureau pour l'union de retraités
des clayes-sous-bois la période coville
était très compliqué pour ce public
vulnérable l'association qui organise
des activités comme des lotos ou encore
dégoûté à des perdu 50 adhérents sur ces
200 monde ça a vraiment été très dur
pour l'association personne ne voulait
me boulay aller à la salle lorsque ça
avait ouvert cette journée du forum a
permis à l'association de recruter une
vingtaine de nouveaux adhérents durant
la pandémie le numérique a aidé à
maintenir un lien social pour ces
personnes parfois isolés on a pu
communiquer avec beaucoup de personnes
qui étaient bloquées chez elles très
seule et ça nous a bien
bien aidés on sent nettement que
maintenant les personnes reprennent et
reviennent et ont envie de participer à
nouveau avec plus de 300000 euros de
subventions versées chaque année les
clayes-sous-bois sûr que le secteur
associatif s'est bien maintenue dans la
vie cette édition 2022 du forum des
associations est revenue à des niveaux
de fréquentation d'avant crise sanitaire
[Applaudissements]